you have to be very careful with praise
oh yeah because in the example that I
give in the corner of MMA fighters if
you tell a guy hey good job you know
your will you won that last round keep
just keep doing what you're doing he's
going to back off yeah he's going to
back off and guess what the other
corners telling them you lost that round
you need to step it up you need to get
aggressive and that's what they're going
to do they're going to get out there
because I'll tell you most people in an
MMA fight MMA fight is a it's like
wrestling it's a very intense cardio
activity you're good everybody's going
to be tired because just about everybody
me obviously so when you get two guys
well let me let me rephrase that when
you get two guys that are evenly matched
and are going at it hard they're both
going to be tired and so they're going
to want a little bit of a rest so if you
give them that opportunity to back off
the throttle just a little bit
subconsciously they're going to do it
because they think they're doing good
they think that won that last round so
you can see that all the time you see I
mean it happened it happened with Ronda
you know they're saying hey good job
good job
you're looking good and she's getting
crushed that's kind of a bad example but
anyway that you got to be careful that
in in I've told this story before but
when my tasking was going through
training and we were doing CQC so close
quarters combat drills we're going to
the kill house over and over and you
know we broke for lunch or something we
come back from lunch and the guy does
the cadre they're like hey you guys are
kicking ass this is great keep it up you
guys are the best cast you two we've
seen out here guys crushing it and
literally the next run guys go in the
house they screw everything up they've
missed targets just a disaster and I
talked to the Contra I'm like don't ever
tell my guys again that's are the best
guys in the world don't don't tell them
that you can tell them good job but
don't be telling them they're the best
people in the world just doesn't work
and so that's kind of what happened you
know here now the thing is this doesn't
mean that you can never give anybody
credit or never give anyone praise
because you absolutely have to do that
but what you have to do you have
proactively can owner act the mental
lapse and intensity that's about to take
place because you just complement so how
do you do that
so let's say you're on the lacrosse
field or the soccer field you bring the
boys and you say look guys good half
good first half you took it to them you
showed them that we can hang with them
you played them even that's fine
here's the problem even isn't good
enough we need to get out there and play
harder we need to step it up I actually
want you guys to play like murderers
that's what I want to do I want you to
win every loose ball I want you to make
every tackle I want you to get your head
on every ball that's in the air you
stick to them on defense I don't even
want them to be able to breathe I want
you to work them into the ground
I want pressure pressure up front
pressure in the midfield and pressure on
D you make them fight for every inch
every ball and every breath I want you
to go out there and take their souls so
you got a camera head you know you gotta
count as a good job thing so in MMA it's
the same thing you know hey good round
there's a closed round but a good round
but listen you can't let up right now
you need to step it up he knows he has
to step it up I'm telling you he knows
he's got to step it up and if you come
out weak he's gonna get the upper hand
right away you need to put him away you
go out there and crush him crush his
soul turn it on and put this guy away I
want you to kill him so that's what you
need to do with that now for tactical
training same thing because you know I
know this police officers and SWAT teams
and keep in guys that are in the
military you're doing tactical training
all the time and you're going to see
that as the team comes together they're
going to start to do good but like I
said if you give them too much they're
gonna slack right so you know when
you're running your tactical training
you for your guys you say look hey guys
I see some good progress out there we're
making some good runs
let me say it's not good enough right
right now okay this is the deal the
enemy can rely on luck we can't we rely
on our training we train to be prepared
for anything that the enemy throws at us
so we're going to work as hard as we can
and be as perfect as we can so we are
ready for the worst-case scenario so get
jacked up for another run right now and
I want you to go in there like a band of
bloodthirsty Viking shock troops on a
dam berserker rage and crush this so you
want to bring that kind of counters
right and then in combat again I just
was talking to some guys yesterday and
it's the same thing like complacency is
the worst thing that can happen with
your team when you're in the combat
scenario so over your combat you know
it's look hey guys we're running some
good operations right we got the upper
hand and that's good but it's not good
enough we cannot be complacent and we
can't take our foot off the enemy's
throat we are going to be relentless we
are not going to give him the chance to
regroup he will not get the chance to
recover
there will be no downtime for the enemy
and I'll tell you what I don't even want
the enemy to have a chance to bury their
dead we are not going to stop until
there is nothing left to pursue and no
one left to bury so sharpen up your
knives load up your magazines because we
got work to do so again we got a counter
you know the compliments and balance
essentially what I'm doing in each one
of those you know situations I'm
balancing the positive affirmations of
what is happening with some new goals
and new objectives that will ensure that
there will be no slack no
hi oh yeah